It's a spectacle that's hard to believe.
Standing before us is Sea Emperor Kaku,
a master that represents China.
It's a miracle that he's participating.
It's a miracle that he's even standing.
It's hard to believe he's fighting!
Begin!
It has begun! Sea Emperor versus Sea King!
This fight would normally
be a clear victory
for the higher-ranked Sea Emperor Kaku.
However!
The age gap is a whopping 121 years!
Sea King Samwan is 25 years old.
At this age, he's full of promise.
I have heard that Samwan's master,
Ryusho So,
went to Thailand 18 years ago.
His daily wages came from
winning cash in Muay Thai matches.
He witnessed a young Samwan
playing around with a cobra,
and that was the historic moment
when Chinese Kenpo
and Muay Thai met by chance.
Then he got lessons for ten years.
They both moved to Hong Kong.
He won all his Raitai matches.
A couple years ago,
the Chinese Ministry of Martial Arts
finally gave the title of Sea King
to Samwan of Thailand.
Look at that!
He moved forward before we realized it.
Sea Emperor Kaku still has his glasses on.
It's not real.
Life force, breathing, fa jin...
It's all make-believe.
You call it martial arts, but it's all
just physical ability.
It's a world where you use
your body logically.
There's no magic there.
Faster...
Faster!
And, with more speed.
Flick!
It's over!